what would you like a freestyle rap
about
labia majora thank you very much the
larger of the lake man you didn't
realize there there's actually four
labia right
there's the the big old elephant ears
and then there's the kind of like you
know sides of a stingray just a little
bit
language my favorite of the lady the
ones you can see more right yeah yeah
who doesn't love a big old puffy pair of
lips it's nice lovely love them special
oh oh yeah right like what
maybe Majora cool beside this here
there's this triangle which is like a
rapper what did you say Bad Bunny are
you are you Puerto Rican yeah you're
very are you just watching me being like
now you're not gonna rap as well as Bad
Bunny
um cool Bad Bad Bunny I may take as
someone who listen listens to rap but
not really to Bad Bunny and that's no
disrespect to him I'm sure he's very
very good I just find it very boring to
have every beat that I hear just go
like does every song need to have that
be it doesn't but Bad Bunny will be the
suggestion I might take it in different
Avenues Bad Bunny lady Majora gosh
you're also quiet and respectful this is
the only time A hip-hop show that
everyone's just gone will be as quiet as
we possibly can we're so excited it's
like when Kanye Rants and everyone
listens going yeah but we paid 120
dollars mate so do a song Middle of the
room so far lady Majora Bad Bunny what
would you like a rap battle
bubble tea I beg your partner bubble tea
lovely stuff they even saying bubble tea
and not Boba Tea because I learned that
that in Taiwan they laugh at us in the
West for calling it boba tea because
Boba means massive boobs in Taiwan and
so they think we're very silly bubble
tea lovely love it Bubble Tea Corner of
the room over there and don't worry the
sun coming to you last bubble tea bat
bunny the lady majority what do you guys
want to rap about
farming thank you yes are you yourself a
marijuana phone
no why did you just go no what's wrong
with that that sounds like an amazing
job
Justin what is your job
an Advertiser do you work in at
pretending on marijuana no no no okay
you're not going to say advertising
phone because you don't want to be
connected with marijuana because yeah
it's a deviant hippie drug marijuana
farming boba tea labian Majora Bad Bunny
final Enclave what would you like a rap
about
don't see animals
so wait what was the first word you said
deep oh dear where's your accent from uh
Australia yeah cool
animals that they say animals
so deep sea animals
I'm gonna go in deep sea creatures it's
more phonetically pleasing
um deep sea creatures marijuana farming
that's some beautiful assonance in that
well done
um we've got lady Majora we've got Bad
Bunny
and what was that middle of the room on
again
bubble tea of course I can't really
forget that well this is this is what
we're going to do we're gonna do a
freestyle rap about all that [ __ ] that's
a wrap made up on the spot based
entirely on your suggestions not written
not prepared not rehearsed and I would
like you to know that it's not going to
be anywhere near as atrociously [ __ ] as
you're expecting it to be because you're
all so patiently waiting for this to
absolutely bomb but it's uh it's it's
gonna be amazing
will make you feel whole it will
complete you in the high pressure
environment those creatures at the
bottom of the sea you'll get your wish
Australian voice saying rap about an
angler fish that's the one with the tiny
light on the prong walking over there
deep sea no Pond no tiny little river I
feel a little quiver when I see the sea
an enemies start to Slither a sea
cucumber oh wish I went snorkeling down
there Great Barrier Reef and hit me
shooting out all of the life I can see
fills me weekly now come with me I'll be
asking you to sip upon bubble tea maybe
over there Far East Taiwanese if you
want to get a good drink and you go
there basically caffeine with the
tapioca tiny little Spears the milk not
clear it's kind of opaque translucent in
here you've got to make sure you get a
large straw otherwise it sucks and you
can't get more it'd be stop there in the
tube I'll be like bubble tea what
problems wrong with you suck suck it
gets to my throat the problem too many
Spears at night jokes start to block my
belly my Adam's Apple swells I say oh I
worry it won't end well I try and reach
back to my tonsils and grab it and then
I pull it out and I see a bunny rabbit
over there he says I am being funny I
like to chew carrots [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm a
bunny whoa
I'm bad what do you no joking in the lab
I'm smoking every day get to marijuana
I'm talking the Bad Bunny he's a great
rap star but I know none of his songs so
this is where we are
charmer hopping in the field spies a
marijuana farmer the guy walks in he's
like our best boast all the bunnies over
here check it on the West Coast I'll be
growing showing all my Mary Jane get the
sun coming down UV with the flame maybe
grow inside you know that I'm on it get
my big green leaves female hydroponic if
you get the males it will cut down your
size of your yield why because the
flowers fertilize and then it doesn't
make the buds you can't get sticky
Advertiser over there are you with me
for you let me blow it up like a labia
majora
it's Heaven Sent so pleasant with the
ears looking like an elephant Indian
Africa doesn't matter the size a spider
fix my eyes between the sides I see the
those labia majora with the urgency and
let me say this there's no need for
surgery if they're puppy if they're
bloated I'm still like yes I'll give it
full throat it give the lady head I'm
sucking like a leaf and like it gets
stuck in my throat like boba tea
[Applause]